Now, let's actually start looking at
how we would represent a digital image as a function.
We've already looked at, that I've given all images an axis basically kind of
traversing, and in continuous variables x and y.
Or, indices in the discreet space, like a matrix, with i or j.
We've also discussed that I want to start representing this image as a matrix,
so here is basically a six-by-six matrix.
Now I've filled this matrix in with some values.
Again, there are values that vary from 0 to 255.
The intensity values of each and
every pixel of this six-by-six just a sample image that we we want to look at.
Now what we want to try to see is, okay, what would this kind of a function or
a matrix have in terms of functional characteristics and
how would we actually look at that signal?
One way of looking at this would be in the continuous store form.
And remember when I actually previously showed you this example of
just doing a slice and looking at the variables recorded.
Actually generate a plot very similar to this.
So if I was to just look at the, this axes of six values.
And this, of course, is just a pictorial of a much bigger image.
It would start showing your continuous signal
varying in different intensity values.
And of course the way we can actually represent that continuous signal,
there are various ways that is possible and
we will be looking at that in a future lecture.
Discrete signal on the other hand would just be these discrete functions at
each and every index value with no continuation going on between them.
But again, it captures a whole lot of detail in a discrete form for
an image like this.
Also another way to look at the same matrix, or
same kina for information would be looking at it with a height map on an image.
So again, on this instance what I do is I look at the y axis and
the x, the x axis.
I just turned it around just to help us visualize this better.
And on the third dimension, the top one,
I would be basically showing the intensities.
That's what this image represents.
If you look at the same mandrill image, now remember,
the intensity values of one or higher zero would be black.
So here, for everywhere the blacks are, you see kind of a a valley.
And then you start seeing peaks and a lot of detail where the whites are.
And actually you can see kind of the ridges forming.
So in essence, this starts making it look like small hills, and
mountains, and ranges, and stuff like that.
We'll be looking at it more carefully, and
I'll actually be even showing you animated versions of this in a bit.
That'll start kind of explaining what are the values of these types of, or
what is the value and what are the advantages of this kind of an image.